don't ask a question on episode 200 of
the askgaryvee show
don't call yet if you do I'm not gonna
pick up we're not
show me live on what on YouTube we're
literally live on YouTube thank you the
book yeah yep it is already which is so
cool so here's another thing let's get
up on my channel so I'm live on YouTube
360 what's going on all right don't
worry release to it here we go
people have a number down you rock I'm
going to go into the show I'm going to
talk about use the money to show you
rock
then D rock you're gonna show the phone
number on my chat a little bit maybe
other than that and then we'll start
answering questions ready good all right
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
200 of the ask gary vee show it's a very
special episode stepmom show the
characters around couple more peeps in
the house any of course Brittnay is in
the house Andrews got info here on
Facebook Lyman and Andy on Google 360
video live but oh yeah as excited I'm so
200 we decided you know I was top 100
show clip from it Stefan hood over here
episode 100 you actually you know
brought a lot of you together we did a
live show and was so two hundred we're
doing a call-in show Saudi rock want to
show everybody
Facebook the phone number that's right
nine four nine four two seven nine eight
three three call the askgaryvee show and
get your question answered in the of are
you ready for the call-in show I didn't
want you ever put in the me donation
nothing you've never been one of my two
assistants for the last three weeks or
so I don't know I so what do you think
give everybody the things that you're
allowed to say what what's the biggest
surprise so far the biggest surprise
I've even so close to the ecosystem yet
I've been around for years for years you
say you're gonna be there even on team
carried me for right but now you're in
it no closer than ever right and so
what's the UH what's the big surprise I
don't know you know he's following me
all day Lou scenarios
he can't see the parallel like that's
the part of people yeah yeah the thing
is happening that you know actors do
it's scary as [ __ ] of all because wow
I'm doing the ten minute meetings me and
Sandy
this is collecting just enormous amount
the pressure
alright nine four nine four two seven
nine eight three three calling now I
will answer you that's right that's fine
uh Facebook live call in nine four nine
four two seven nine eight three three
with your question and I'll answer it
live on the show I'm excited about this
callin now we just sit here and
excitingly wait for the phone calls I
was really impressed with everybody
waiting to call look I'm very very
thankful Facebook oh you look so funny
so many of them are on their phone so
what do they do like I mean it's so
weird now
like what I used to do this live
streaming on Ustream and have people
call they were like in their desktop and
they would just pick up their phone you
know now it's like all-encompassing in
one device so let me just see this one
more time
2500 it's not working a lot of people
say it's not working
one nine four nine four two seven nine
eight three three do you think we're
getting so many calls it broke doesn't
go through holy crap are we getting so
many not available Andy what happened
did we break it lives got busy exactly
did we get this number
yeah a month we can do that no this is
we should give me it
do we have any like Google Voice numbers
I'm not sure I can I can try do we wait
Google Voice why because the
vaynernation break anything so yeah
what's working it's all busy signal's
home from Gilbert Dominguez you over to
Vegas to accept press one what animal
Gilbert yes how many brother pretty good
pretty good in yourself tremendous what
is your question well my question is I
have a upcoming provisional patent on a
warehouse product I was wondering what I
could do to help prepare myself to
becoming a future business owner or
entrepreneur or what not so what are you
worried about you I don't know what can
I do whether some books I could help
prepare myself because I'm going to end
up having to uh like cleaning where
houses just to get my product up there
and I was wondering I don't know I have
all this stuff coming up they're gonna
have to try to accomplish I just need
some any type of business advice well
let me give you good advice you're gonna
get nothing from reading a book no books
going to tell you like what to do what
you need to do is wrap your head around
that you have to bleed out of your
[ __ ] eyes and work 24/7 365 there's
no there's no advice that I can give you
like it's gonna be about putting in the
hard work and learning the ropes
I'd also give you a huge advice go ask
questions to all your future customers
whoever you're going to sell to go ask
them questions the best way to be
successful business is to deliver for
people what they actually want and the
best way to figure out what they want is
to ask questions attachment spectators
to the user so that that's what I'm
going offer okay this thing is it's okay
it's a dust mop and that hasn't been
altered since 1993 so what I've done is
the lemon is and it's four new
attachments to it it's like it is it is
right the future of Denmark so listen
well I don't give a [ __ ] if it's the
future of human beings if the customers
don't eventually like it or cater it's
not going to matter so just because you
love your dust mop doesn't mean the
market does so you have to go out there
and really get people to give a crap
great content get it into people's hands
give away something for free get it out
there got it okay thank you thank you
all right ninety nine or two seven nine
eight three three what did that work
yeah I know but now like I love it we
just got to get the call mechanisms now
because the call-in show is though I
love this the calling show is super fun
like super super fun I just don't know
who's calling right now like are we are
we still like busy like I love that we
just tried [ __ ] because I love the
people who can actually watch this that
was good
they split people here why Kim Gary just
call me comments a repeating live
straight-up busy it's busy hmm
put the phone number in again nine four
nine four two seven ninety three three a
minute yeah it's fine but I mean I don't
think that's what I'm sure somebody's
calling should I just call people yeah
so I just tell people on Facebook put
their phone numbers and just call well
no you have their number
right I'm excited I can see the people
that you have the numbers yeah all right
numbers milk right all right calling
some people this is for you guys and
episode 200 cuz I don't meet this boring
we have nine one four four six nine yeah
eight six Sansa Carrie Carrie Carrie
Carrie I exactly
Anthony how are you it's Carrie me Gary
how are you so nice to hear from you
great to hear friend talk how are you my
love come come what's your question
brother so my question is Gary amongst
all the noise from all the snapchats and
all the tweets and all the Facebook
postings what catches your attention
what do you look for any value to want
to do business with somebody they will
want to connect with somebody you mean
all the people that are hitting me up
like just like do this with me do that
with me like what catches my my
attention right cuz you talk a lot about
Twitter video you know I got my you know
I got my interview with Tony Robbins do
a you know you I didn't have a Twitter
video that guy yeah so trying to you
know land meetings and connect with
people what do you look for what's a
value to you amongst the thousands of
snaps and the thousands of post it
really just didn't know what your
thoughts are
so unlike Tony Robbins and other things
that nature and all these other
executives I talk so much about getting
to people and I tell people get to
people about what happened for you that
man I get so much of that back at me
like this but you know it's really
pissing me off Jab Jab Jab right hook
the amount of people that are doing
things for me that don't have the pure
intent in mind they're just doing it
because they want something in return
and then I'm giving you things that are
I don't want your [ __ ] jab and conch
I don't want the jabs if you want to
give me like I didn't want
that hat lei I don't want it so I think
that um I think that what I look for is
pure intent and something that brings me
value of the moment for example let me
do something right now on episode 200
I'm about to send an email internally on
vaynermedia on Monday I'm adding a new
team member to my team called
distribution like I want to know like
this thing's we've all talked about
maybe you guys know but I'm gonna go
different than one person and their
whole job with 15 hours a day is to get
distribution for my content which means
for 15 hours a day you have to reach out
to 200,000 websites in the world that I
think could take the led the askgaryvee
show and my articles and want to
distribute them and use them the way the
Forbes in the HuffPo and others do it so
you know I'm looking for things that I
need if somebody happened to have been
paying attention to me and realize that
distribution mattered and tweet it out
hey carry me I want to do distribution
for you I will guarantee you then I'll
get 11,000 websites in a hundred days to
distribute your content that would have
caught my attention because that was
something I needed so whatever I care
about and I need if I see it being
communicated that's what I read back to
calm that's also Gary listen I
appreciate so last thing I'll hang up is
it's all about fundamentals picking up
the phone doing the research find out
what's value yes valuable to you that
what I think is that that's right Gary
thank you so very much
take care of nine four nine seven nine
you couldn't call turn off call screen
see what happens yeah okay don't worry
that's here to call give me another
number here's the key the number thing
number one thing keep calling because
the number one thing I wanna do Andy is
I want to be marking all these cell
phone numbers on Facebook to sell them
some more books we're going to Lexington
eight live another eight five nine three
two one three two one one three seven
five one three SOT a lot of these people
could get random calls if other people
have animation sorry
Gary Vee how's it going good man who is
this
this is chase Fairchild how are you
doing I'm doing super well chase thanks
for being on the show episode 200 thank
you so much brother it's awesome look
why we got through yeah what's your
what's your question so my friends and I
are starting a creative agency good I
know I think I know a thing or two about
that okay and so we follow your work we
read a lot of your stuff and we're
trying to get every dollar done zero
before we start with launched August
first how do you think is the best way
for us to get over the fear of failing
at this because it's kind of taken elite
we're in a we're currently an in-house
marketing department for a twenty one
chain retail store I think you guys are
negative you guys are taking the leap
you guys are rounding the troops and
saying screw this place we're going to
do our thing you've got to first decide
here are the ways to do it you do the
emotional and the practical when you
take a leave the practical is all how
many of you are doing it three the three
you have to figure out worst-case
scenario nothing goes well how long can
you survive on your savings or you're
willing to be entrepreneurial get out
got it
yeah so got it really need this inner
circle and you go India how long can you
last I mean he says 18 months
Andrew how long can you last four months
Andy how long can you last two years we
know we're only as strong as our weakest
link god damn anthems oh my god more
months we can talk about that number one
do you think that the three of you can
go without any sales for a year yeah I
love the good thing is we have investors
from the companies that got behind us
and they're like you kind of have us we
can have a stake in it a little bit if
it if it fails so great huh
so you so it's a set sounds so it sounds
like you created the practical version
and now you just have to make the
emotional version too many people you
know I've been talking about this fake
entrepreneurship if you're scared to
make the jump you still have
entrepreneurial tendencies you're not an
entrepreneur yet it's why you've worked
in a company other first place
you just got to make the jump or not
it's like swimming either jump in the
pool and you go or you don't the end
yeah
that's why and then when so like that's
kind of my fear because it you know
we're just starting this it's it's kind
of new frontier you know and do you know
scared nothing's gonna happen you could
always go back to the goddamn job yeah
I'm woods what's gonna happen I like
people to make fun of you like your
mom's gonna say you failed like who
gives a [ __ ] go try it doesn't work and
go don't care what other people think
it's the only reason you're scared yeah
when there's your house your partner
your child your mother
whoever it is eliminate those voices
listen to yourself and know that if you
fail you go back into it and nothing bad
will happen but it's the that ever
happened oh yeah all right brother
what's happening Oh Milwaukee in the
house are you a are you a huge Brewers
fan
Baltimore Ravens fans I'm saying what
you're pushing brother look okay okay
okay Hey
so I started not too long ago call ended
forever okay work with I work with
elementary schools and I do workshop but
a pertinent to like forensics or speech
innovative familiar with that yes and
one of the hardest things to do is to
get into the schools and provide those
workshops yes because it's like really
hard to discourage bureaucrats and
goddamn principals and superintendents
and all stuck in our average not all of
you but the motion so like I really want
to change the educational system up so
like first of all let me throw a quick
plug in say if your elementary school
principal and you want to work with me
get me up and you know a little right
hook and and also know like how do I get
type of gatekeeper daunting the best way
to sell is to not sell the best way in
the world to sell is that people come to
you instead of you going to them put out
content write an article on medium six
mistakes the superintendent makes then
post it and then spend a hundred bucks
on amplifying the ad in Milwaukee in
that general area and I guarantee for
superintendents and teachers will pass
it on it's put out content film court
that the stuff that you can film some of
them will be private and you can't the
answer Dante the full answer is making
content that's a gateway drug to
penetrate the decision-makers in school
systems got it yes okay last part with
the question then how do I like how do I
do that with no money like can you write
how are you write like I'm okay can you
do okay so I would do well I would do
audio because I like the way you talk
like I would do sound slab posts I would
post them on your Facebook page you
might have one fan right now and then I
would reach out to everybody you know
and ask them to share it in Milwaukee
and literally ghetto
like I used to do it report and search
people talking about your subject
matters and reply to them money is a
tricky thing
money tricks people people think they
need money you don't need
money you need hustle okay more money if
you want it I don't want to hear you
[ __ ] watching Ravens at Monday night
well actually after that you gotta say
the two o'clock in the morning you can
go to Twitter search search the 5-mile
radius of Milwaukee and hit up anybody
talking about school issues you can put
out content rally up all your friends
all 47 people your [ __ ] auntie I
don't give a [ __ ] and ask her to share
it and it just starts it starts you got
to start from the bottom okay okay
alright Dante get it so YouTube is 369
four nine four two seven nine eight
three three how many people on Facebook
live of 0.9 almost 4,000 people or
thousand four thousand let's go Texas
please get your name after the tone
and Google Voice will try to rely on the
voice go yeah d-fenders dear Gary Mugabe
hello it's Gary Vaynerchuk how are you
good I guess I need to take take this
off
all right Gary yeah I can hear you okay
great I was uh I was hearing the
feedback from watching it and hear my
voice no way yeah Ethan Garcia Greene
from the Houston Texas they got Houston
h-town what up I was introduced from a
friend of mine method 21 they told me
about you guys because I was starting up
my business and definitely is moving a
fire underneath me so I started up
unison Industrial Solutions okay they
tell consulting company I was mentoring
some kids from the University of Houston
they didn't have any direction when they
finished their their degree so what I
certainly doing was introducing them to
I chose taking them out Higgins to the
some of the networking that's giving
them a crash course at all the gas yep
then this would be a great business to
start so be a zone so important so real
quick my man this is the askgaryvee show
so I gotta ask
what's the question I appreciate the
contract how do you keep it together I
wanted to ask suggestions of a CRM
software that I utilize to keep
everything together yeah I want to kind
of give you an overview yeah and then I
appreciate all the different people
together and then maybe if I can do that
yeah I want to be able to white label at
CRM got it so you actually want to build
a CRM for people that do stuff like you
or you want to figure out what's the
diversity make an excel sheet on Google
Docs it's free and Salesforce and the
answers probably go up right so I mean I
mean are you really saying I don't want
to do a service business I want to build
a SAS business and create a product no
so we do sales consulting for more than
gaps and so I wanted to be able to
cultivate the farm teach these kids that
way they have some direction and then
maybe even while they're going to school
give them practical application of what
they're learning okay and then give them
a crash course in the oil and gas so
that they have a goal in mind for their
innovation and so and then possibly hire
them okay and so the question is how do
you organize their information to be
most efficient or what want to make sure
I understand the question
correction it would be keeping keeping
all the students together and be able to
categorize them and be able to find out
what they're studying whether it's
engineering a deal honestly yeah
honestly like Salesforce or Google Docs
like it's not super complicated those
are two plays okay what about a white
label CRM do you have any suggestions on
the white label would I meaning you want
to create one or who's out there that
white labels like what do you want to do
with the white label CRM I want on there
so we will see around I want to be able
to give these students during on with
oil and gas people I don't I don't I
don't know but the good news is you know
there's something way better than the
askgaryvee show you should write this
down you got a pen already late gee oh
oh
now got it got it that's it when you
want information my friends Google is
better than me you know if you want
context I might be better respect yep
thank you
all right good experiment like this one
more Scott this is a duty try to call
but he called back you meant to
voicemail and I just caught it I don't
know I once got to feel the pain okay
that's right for you Scott Scott were
sorry and ease everything show any space
is in attempt all right fun experiment I
gotta go I just want to take a few
seconds to thank all of you for allowing
me to get the episode 200 it's fun
because episode 200 I think you could
see little clunky we're trying to figure
it out but there's clearly the pieces do
you up what do you see like people like
like right there's the pieces the
foundation of some sort of innocent next
chapter of the askgaryvee show where we
finally get rid of each other riff
Raff's over here get rid of the knife
that finished technology is hanging over
them we have figures we hope with that
do you have any job be a much more
intensive you think anyway I want to
thank you guys so much for supporting
the show supporting me watching CNBC the
other night appreciate that the snapchat
but barely bees all that be rockin are
gonna be back to filming those so that
should be fun and thank you so much
reading part of this journey I
appreciate you tremendously and we will
be back for episode 201 shortly probably
Monday right Monday and we interesting a
lot of Q&A format actually that's the
question today give me the direction
you'd like to see episode 200 or 300 you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
on this episode we do a call-in show you
Gary where are you did Josh how are you
pretty good yeah um so I just noticed
you're wrapping up wrapping up a show so
for a question
I'm not wrapped up I'm finished you're
finished
doing this question for you so what is
it much in the answer of all time though
so I have a few businesses on I'll keep
it brief so when when do you decide if
you start a business okay I have two
right now one of them one kind of
dropped passion and my partner's don't
really have the drive to keep going on
yeah at one point do you decide that's
our on the towel and how exactly you
know have you ever had any situations
where you kind of found yourself in
there a lot of businesses where I was
the minority partner non driver of the
businesses that have failed and the way
I do it is I just take it for a loss and
I talk it up you try to sell it for
whatever scraps it's worth or sell it
back to your partners that are running
it or you just you walk away it's a zero
it's over it's done or if you feel like
crap but I work seven years and it's
worth real money you sell it and you
sell it from a non leverage position
which means you'll get less money for it
but it's still okay because clearly by
the tone of your voice and the fact that
you have passion for number one you've
got to let it go yeah well you know you
work 90 hours a week in it it gets tough
to spray your empty please any later
finalize it on place you know the real
question is how much money are you going
to lose and are you willing to lose it
and a lot of times what people realize
they don't want to lose the $40,000 or
the five thousand dollars or five
hundred million dollars and they could
make seven hundred million or five
thousand times spoiling if you get back
your 40 hours from that thing or 30 or
20 or even 10 you might make more money
deploying against the thing you care
about than the money left on the table
so xyc you know you're leaving a hundred
thousand that you're giving up and
you're like [ __ ] I can't give that up
but we don't realize the 18 hours back
and the happiness and not the dream in
the emotional dream of 100 hours a week
on that other thing allows you to make a
hundred twenty thousand on your new gig
yeah I know that's that's that's exactly
where I'm at is you know how much how
much more money can I make other
business what they doesn't a part time
see if this was an attorney who's it for
me and yeah yeah yeah no it's totally
clear numbers are businesses with
friends I always like no I'm not true
always from businesses and friends the
people you don't mean rating just listen
I mean listen it didn't work out it's a
life lesson right
but um but you know that's the [ __ ]
game baby this is entrepreneurship yeah
yeah no for sure every every every call
from unknown caller hello hello hey guys
it's Carlos oh this is actually Indiana
Gary had to leave to get a cat so I'm
going to continue trying to you know
communicate in whatever place to do that
for sure
there's the best place to hit up Gary
yeah definitely hey guys thank you so
much for you know the effort and making
this awesome this was some QVC ship I
love it I swear to God saying like the
value of transit communicate we can
communicate with all you guys from the
beta nation whatever it's been saying
when you guys really did like that this
is DC is you know what lives
broadcasting life of Rachel's live and
periscope and meerkat this is what
really business value this is a the
value of the property be seeking of life
streaming so thank you so much for doing
them of course thank you for calling
sorry Gary wasn't here
hello phone huh there's gonna be meeting
in here later [ __ ] and they just end it
right there she
experiment very interesting trying to go
to the Hangout Jordan does he carry need
this hounded by guys next watching